on était ici des familles défavorisées
et orphelins de surcroît et c'est
pourquoi d'ailleurs on nous appelle
naturellement les orphelins de thomas
sankara
à
[Musique]
navet entre 12 14 et 16 ans à l'époque
comment sankara avec l'idéal
révolutionnaire
décida de nous envoyer à cuba pour une
formation technique professionnelle et
idéologique
[Musique]
thomas sankara était un père et de mère
et un père comme nous l'apprenons
aujourd'hui notre père spirituel
thomas sankara
arrive à cuba
à 4,27
et il sait jamais de tout un chacun
les
475 garçons et les 135 fille il disait
si si
formez vous bien pour venir développer
votre pays
[Musique]
aujourd'hui nous découvrons
85 de nos camarades qui sont décidés
certains par suicide
245 qui sont à la fonction publique
sous-employé et 460 qui sont
effectivement à chômage du poker
[Musique]